like I saw that that guy asked that
question to Giannis do you consider this
a failure so he gave him a really
intelligent answer and now there's all
this pushback going like uh sounds like
a bunch of excuses all of these [__]
people that are saying that [__] it's
like I want to see your life I want to
see your [__] life and how how you
you you take it to [__] task every
day it's like one team wins it every
year it's practically [__] impossible
to achieve with these guys and when they
don't every single year some fat [__]
a Tommy Bahama shirt just to go like do
you feel like a loser and they're just
trying to piss him off because the whole
year these guys are a foot taller than
them their dicks are a foot longer and
they're banging puss that's over the
horizon in their world so then they get
to just be [__] why don't why doesn't
that [__] nameless [__] who's off
camera in his Loveless [__] marriage
why can't he just come at him you know
do you think your wife considers you a
failure